hi I'm Erik Bosse and Disney's The Lion
King released a trailer that everyone's
talking about
giving us a look at the studio's third
live-action reboot coming in the year
2019 of course live-action is kind of a
loose term all the animals look pretty
animated but who cares I don't want them
to use real lions in the movie it's mean
to Lions and of the humans who would
have to work around them look I'm a Lion
King junkie the 94 classic was the first
movie I saw three times in the movie
theatre as a kid I had a rad Lion King
bedspread I pretended to be a lion for
several years I didn't talk much I ate a
lot of animal look I've come a long way
to break down this trailer for you shot
by shot for all the interesting details
that you might have missed what will be
the same as before and what will have
changed here we go
okay so right away we see that Lion King
2019 director Jon Favreau he directed an
Iron Man and a live-action jungle book
along with Disney's upcoming Mandalorian
Star Wars series we see how Favreau is
recreating most of the exact imagery
from the original film pacifically the
shots from a 94 trailer for that movie
the Sun rising over the African savannah
grazie and antelope lifting its head the
wide shot of Mount Kilimanjaro the
overhead shot of birds flapping over a
river of course we don't see the baby
draft blinking at the steps into the Sun
but that's fine you know it's early it's
early doesn't have to be exact actually
the biggest difference that I noticed
between this footage and the original
Lion King is the color palette like brie
watch the animated circle of life
opening and you can see how the
animators kept switching the color
temperature fiery reds deep greens
dreamy Pink's hazy aqua all to
accentuate the color variety of this
animal kingdom but while the animal
kingdom is certainly rich with diversity
its color palette isn't as exaggerated
as these animated cells in reality it
looks more like their earth tones that
Favreau uses shades of tan green and
brown so while these animals might not
be real the world they occupy is
definitely designed to look a lot more
like ours let's move on everything the
light touches is all kingdom
but a keys time is ruler rises and falls
like the Sun okay we hear the voice of
James Earl Jones returning from the
first movie to once again voice Mufasa
Mufasa Jones is the only major cast
member to return from the first movie
but honestly really is the only one
whose voice is irreplaceable
I mean maybe with exceptions of Nathan
Lane as Timon and Jimmy irons ask our
show us out a gif for is voice and scar
here Billy Eichner voice and Timon Seth
Rogen as Pumbaa Donald Glover as adult
Simba Beyonce as adult Nala alfre
woodard as Surabhi you might know her
from Luke Cage and Captain America Civil
War John Connie as Rafiki he actually
played two challahs fathers Civil War
and black panther John Oliver
Zazu and Michael key Eric Andre and
Florence kazoomba as the hyenas Kamaria
ZZ & Shenzi and kizomba has played the
Dermalogica guard ayo and black panther
and an infinity war now this speech
Mufasa gives is the same morning lesson
that he gives to Simba as a cub in the
old movie everything the light touches
is our kingdom a king's time as ruler
rises and falls like the Sun we also see
this shot of young Simba stepping into
the paw print of his father that
actually comes a little later in the old
movie after the elephant graveyard scare
the nighttime kings of the past speech
of course where Simba realizes he's not
getting ready to take over for his dad
next clip one day the Sun was set on my
time here
and will rise with you as the new king
as mufasa's morning lesson speech winds
up we see these shots so the Stampede
rushing into the canyon this of course
is for Mufasa is terrifying death
sequence I think really closely you can
see tiny Simba kicking up some dust as
he tries to flee yeah hold on to your
butt this movie's gonna hurt all over
again then finally we get the opening
vocals of the circle of life as we swoop
in on Pride Rock the framing matches the
original film almost exactly with the
exception of Zazu not being in this shot
well maybe this is like Prebys point of
view or he's about to fly into it let's
keep going
[Music]
okay some more familiar images here
Rafiki greets Mufasa and anoints the
newborn Simba one little change though
you remember in the original Rafiki
splits open a fruit and spreads the
juice of that fruit on Simba's head here
he rips up a bunch of roots and it
releases a red powder that he uses for
the anointing by the way that fruit is
called a bale Bob it's an African super
fruit with a lot of health benefits it
represents wisdom perhaps Favreau change
that because when you actually rip open
a fresh baby Bob it's not exactly filled
with red fruit juice like a gusher so
making this live action I made if
required a more realistic source of
something bright red to mark with like
this fruit unfortunately it might also
mean leaving out the baby Lions adorable
sneeze mm-hmm if that's not in the final
movie I'm gonna lose my mind by the way
young Simba will be voiced by JD
McCreary and young Nala will be voiced
by shadi right Joseph moving on
okay Favreau also includes these shots
of the draught zebras elephants all
bowing which is pretty crazy to see in
live action considering there's no
freaking way that all of these animals
would be anywhere near each other in the
wild like as a kid seeing this in
cartoon form it made sense one big happy
Kingdom but now I'm like if there's a
cheetah anywhere in that crowd and it
doesn't pounce on a zebra it's stupid i
watch planet earth every wild animal
that you see it's starving to death so
eat your neighbors no no and I will
always love an abrupt cut from Pride
Rock to the tidal card
Favreau just really gets what feels to
bring back okay after listing off the
cast this trailer gives us one final
moment man gotta love the title card
booms by the way if this trailer sounds
extra percussion II it might be because
Elton John and Tim Rice's original music
is being mixed in with scoring from Hans
Zimmer the king of heavy percussion
and the voice of Mufasa saying remember
comes of course from the ghost vision
scene that comes later in the movie
[Music]
but the cloud imagery here looks a lot
more nebulous suggesting to me that
ghost Mufasa might be more elemental and
natural than you know
Mufasa shaped cloud but that's okay
because a cloud can really take any
shape if you squint your eyes enough
like these kind of look like lions to me
or just gasp me everything's gasps the
final shot shows adult Simba back on
Pride Rock
burning with strength this kind of looks
like the end of the film
you know those early morning hours when
the dust was settling after his battle
with scar so I guess we're to expect
that this Lion King live-action version
isn't really gonna play around with the
story too much it's gonna start and in
the same way same Hamlet in the
Serengeti plot with catchy Elton John
songs that we know and love and honestly
it's where the best no need to fix what
ain't broke just make sure to get that
sneeze in there yeah
but I'm curious to know from you guys
looking at this new voice cast which
actors do like better in these roles
than the original cast and which do you
think will have to really win you over
to replace the originals comment down
below with your thoughts and follow new
rock stars on twitter and instagram at
new rock stars and ramayana takes you
can follow me on twitter and instagram
at a boss and of course subscribe to new
rock stars for breakdowns of all the
stuff you love in case you want to know
what I think about the cast
yay for Glover Oh for know Whoopi or JT
t but I get it it's not the early 90s
anymore you can't go home again hmm you
know could you show me that sneeze again
[Music]